oh yeah it's the Lord's Day
[__] strap a para
you dare enter this house on the Lord's
Day you bad [__]
it's a beautiful [__] day to be
alive thank God the Lord gave you
another day to sling dick and to let
these [__] know what's in your
heart and what's in your soul we got a
couple things to talk about in the
Lord's Day number one my heart goes out
to Houston Texas one of the best [__]
cities in the country you understand me
real real I don't give a [__] some of
the best food from Barnaby's to handy
chance dumpling palace I hear Alan
parkways I'm the [__] water people
are swimming to kolache places my heart
goes out to you okay spooky
Bobby Crystal [__] Pete Farrelly you
know I love you [__] I got you
we're gonna be down there this afternoon
with a [__] helicopter you understand
me I don't want nobody floating on ramps
like Katrina like black people [__]
out there forget about it was showing up
down at number two the kind of McGregor
[__] Mayweather fight was sensational
last night kinda has nothing to be
ashamed of Mayweather's a [__]
professional listen I hope you guys
learned something from this fight I
hadn't bet I didn't make any predictions
you know why cuz I wanted to see what
was going on hold on let me take a
little breather and let's take care of
my important thing before we get this
party started we got some great reefer
today we got some Master Kush and this
is what's left of the [__] action
Johnson action bronson we smoked that
first
number one respect the Conor McGregor is
[__] happy soluti one in there before
the [__] tremendous fight the problem
was he wanted because the guy that was
49 I know okay and I didn't know this at
all before the fight I went with
Mayweather I tell you why they said that
if [__] McGregor one Vegas would lose
their ass rule number one
you never see a bookie with a part-time
job that on business to [__] lose I
still didn't bet I still was looking for
an interesting fight and I [__] got
it for you people who are talking [__]
for that the fight was fixed and all
this go to around seven or eight in
between when kind of had nine bags of
ice on them and his head was [__]
spinning like you know so I give my
heart out to Connie for the tremendous
[__] fight listen Mayweather is 14 I
don't know what if i'ma telling you
people what's the most important book
you get right the war of art what's the
first chapter about reconnaissance guess
what Mayweather did he did hit the
proper reconnaissance you were not 49 I
know because you [__] just fight
[__] people and going there with no
plan a man without a plan is not a man
Nietzsche he went in there so if you
learned anything from this fight no
learn that everything you do in your
life has to be preparation even if
you're walking down the [__] Street
you have to know what side you're gonna
walk on a case Isis attacks or some
jerk-off shows up with [__] eggs you
don't [__] know but I hope you took
that from the fight
can't afford [__] tremendously
Mayweather was a genius he [__] and
sucked him in for four or five or six
rounds and then he unleashed on Imfurst
he started with singles then doubles
then three-point combinations then four
point and he nullified [__] Connors
left hand so her being an MMA is taking
notes for you MMA boxing people go [__]
yourself you don't even know what the
[__] you're talking about
last night you learned what true boxing
was it's a [__] plan and it's
sticking to it and that's it that's it
and that's that beside that now you know
what you need to do this week
preparation Monday through Friday these
I'm not gonna be walking around and it's
late but there's a [__] that's when you
[__] strike that's when you walk them
you leave the house with eight [__]
knives
what kind of sense preparation is the
[__] key and they I like it it do I
learned the [__] lesson last night
so that's your [__] week's assignment
preparation before you make a move you
know exactly what that dudes gonna do
how he's gonna do it he warmed down and
they just gotta throw firecrackers at
him but I did kind of fight bet no no no
was it an early stop it's listen guys
let me explain something to you you knew
the damage he was about to do what kind
of is when I get here where was laser
beams and we're not in business to her
tongue with Jon Jones gun rind the
[__] jumping up and down with her
what we gonna do if Carla's walking
around half a BOTS [__] stuttering
and [__] like that it was a tremendous
fight if you paid the yardstick and
you're upset go [__] yourself you know
I'm saying go [__] yourself what do you
gonna do you got something that's why
you got listening to the podcast don't
be a [__] sucker that's the [__]
thing of the week you don't say that's
why I sat back and watched that any
[__] note was gonna happen
prediction if I could predict I bit the
[__] track betting [__] exact ISM
trifecta do you think I'd be on
periscope top and a you [__]
anyway if Sunday you don't give a [__]
write your goals do your push-ups hug
your family tell them you love them tell
them it's gonna be the best way to your
life that you're leaving the house with
[__] to haunt and a [__] fire
cracker [__] machine flying out of ya
she understand me
King Jung Yong Kim whatever that [__]
dude in North Korea he could suck your
dick because just by attitude they can't
stop you this week I'm sorry a little
[__] emotional on the Lord's Day you
know I'm saying I'm gonna do a little
writing imma do little Jiu Jitsu and I'm
gonna hook up with my cousin for lunch
and have a clear [__] day today
look it is [__] dying to come out of
the container
I love spoke with you people you
understand me as far as the podcast will
be out tip-top Magoo 8 a.m. tomorrow ok
I don't wanna hear nothing more that the
fight is fixed I don't wanna hear
nothing about number two that I was 40
[__] years old compared to Conor's
[__] 29 it's science
it memorizes a science it's science
people everything we do has a different
science
with even if it's a [__] art there's
a science wrapped around that one you
guys gonna [__] them realize that [__]
Oh
oh [__] it's gonna be a good day
I should I feel like Conor McGregor in
the 8th round he's all Dizzy's like the
ice bags on but anyway you people bad
[__] and you know I love y'all
right somebody didn't tell you today I'm
gonna [__] tell you you're a bad
[__] go in that shower we'll
grab your [__] nuts and tell the
world somebody sniffing my [__]
nutsack today cuz I ain't got time to
[__] around no more [__] around take
it easy
and number three for you people who get
angered me about that and listen
[__] I be I dance to the beat
of my own drum like your mother told you
when you were six just cause somebody
else jumps off a bridge you're gonna
jump off a bridge what what makes me
[__] Joey beers I do what the [__] I
want to do what I want to do it how the
[__] I want to do it I don't give a [__]
what people are doing you understand me
why be like everybody else your goal is
to be [__] unique your legacy is firm
to say you know what Jimmy McGill was a
solid [__] dude he danced to the beat
of his own drum well yeah I've never
done the MV I don't do a ton of this
[__]
uncle Joey hits for the [__] fence is
like Canseco on steroids if you're gonna
do it do it
if you gotta do ahead ask him break
yourself down for 12 hours I'll [__]
yourself you understand me if you're not
gonna smoke the best the Lord's got too
often you want to dip on the Apple the
Starbucks with your [__] little [__]
friends talking about the economy of
thee you got ecosystem who gives a [__]
okay you're wasting your [__] time
focus on what's in front of you cops up
and say you never get to be stop it now
with that note
it's the first thing you need to be but
type ii is being an individual that's
why i don't give a [__] jack i do what
the [__] i would do and i suggest you to
do the same if you want to make it
happen might be 50 years old listen I
lived my life with a little hat because
you know where I had to be cool [__] G
no [__] P no [__] em all is all about
your world comes up and if you don't
look at it that way don't [__] hang
yourself or something cuz I ain't gonna
[__] get any better huh waiting for
somebody else to prove they could all
suck it dick it's your [__]
world it's the Lord's Day uncle Joey
coming at you and that's just the way
the [__] it is number two you got a
podcast tomorrow coming at you at 8:00
in the morning
and another one on Wednesday and then
it's late but they go live your life if
you sittin there listenin to a podcast
you got do something with your life you
understand me and number three just be
you it all works out oh yeah they didn't
get my my tell a pain I totally about
the scene oh boy in Osaka oh we're do
another pipe for
and I'll send you [__] on your
way I know you guys got [__] to doing
people to see you gotta write your goals
it's gonna be a good day it's gonna be a
[__] good week and most importantly
you're gonna be prepared
nobody can [__] with you this week okay
they want to send missiles you're
sitting down you already know you
already know you're gonna get them I'm
saying as soon as they [__] let that
guy down and it's over
I'm sitting here with these trees around
me a spider just bit me on the foot I
don't give a [__]
[Music]
anyway I love you I have a great day
don't let nobody [__] with you and I
hope you learned something from that
Mayweather McGregor fight last night
there's something there's a silver
lining to everything it had but a
[__] pipe there's a silver lining to
the right
stay black uncle Joey loves you the
podcast 8:00 a.m. tomorrow we're by
nothing Rudy Sarzo have a great Lord's
day with your family and have a great
[__] week we'll bump into each other
somewhere all right stay black